A young priest was always sad.
He was good at his profession but he still had no joy.
He visited a group of wise monks.
When he got to the monks' house, they greeted him and let him in.
The monks asked the priest, "What is the matter?"
The priest said, "I should be happy but I am not."
"I don't know what to do."
The wise monks paused for a minute.
Then one said, "We are convinced of your faith."
"You are a very good priest."
"But to find joy, you have to do more."
"Above all, investigate the elements of your life that you love."
The priest thought that this answer was odd but he was curious.
The next day, the priest thought about his abilities.
He got a few ideas and he did not want to delay any longer.
He liked to draw so he made some cartoons.
He also liked to write so he started a diary.
He was interested in agriculture so he planted some grains.
He made jam from berries.
He made his own labels to put on the jars of jam.
He painted his ceiling.
The priest learned something.
It is not too hard to be happy after all.
All one has to do is find things they like doing and do them!